[Music]
okay gentlemen you get locked
up in prison i wouldn't
i'm a good dude you know yeah video's
over play with me
someone can frame me somebody like me
could frame me for something no yeah i
don't hang out with you oh yeah oh you
don't hang out shady cats i love them
only cool cats
so what's the one thing you would bring
in with you and how would you get it in
through the ass of course
you don't even know what it is a phone a
phone i think so yeah so i could stay
relevant make some tick tocks you know
hopefully do jail tick tocks jail vlog
jail vlogging my vlog would be pretty
dope yep plan my escape with it somehow
ooh a mukbang a jail mukbang yeah i
gotta do jail mukbang you know it's
pretty good that is good uh well you're
you're very good at that by the way um
but he did not put it up his ass what
did he swallowed it he swallowed it oh
stupid
what was it going to do puke it back out
put it up your ass you idiot if i put in
a balloon and then inside i can't even
do like vitamin pills how do you do a
[ __ ] phone why didn't he just do the
large intestine versus the [ __ ] small
one
it's not just girls who have no gag
reflexes sometimes guys you have to
remember that oh he held it at the he
got it in there bud and he swallowed it
like a sword swallower what kind of
phone like a like a motorola razor a
nokia 3310 i knew it was no you can't
vlog on that
i need a modern day you've seen the new
one uh the touchscreen that folds you're
gonna play snake the classic [ __ ]
nokia snake yeah 33 tenths smaller i
know they still had though the smaller
ones do i had that phone in high school
with a get rich or die trying 56
[Laughter]
and the ringtone
the game you should go to jail you
should go to jail for that hard dude 50
cent had a video game that was off the
[ __ ] pain you had a video game yeah
get rich or die trying and he had a
blood in the sand or some [ __ ] he had a
sequel dude
i was hard dude i don't know i'm soft
now dude
when you see that phone and you're going
to jail
that means like he was like this
and he thought about it he goes no my
butthole's too tight
i gotta put it this way no way that
hurts less right i'm doing the pooping
i'm doing it too yeah i'm doing the
pooper yeah i think so too because it
feels good at least you know it feels
good and i'll just go in and out for a
little bit
yeah the vibrate feature yeah
hey call me real quick
they must be
able to like keep their [ __ ] real deep
because when you get processed in jail
they go up they make you blend bend over
and squat oh really yeah they make you
crack a smile you have to pull your
cheeks yeah and then you have to squat
so i'm like
that phone is staying in there if they
if they kestered it do you think these
guys practice
like how do they practice they practice
by getting buff [ __ ]
or you could do that just jamming it in
there i don't want that phone though
like what are you going to do with that
they're preparing that prison pocket
he's like i just [ __ ] love snakes are
you talking about the web capabilities
of it i'm just saying like what are you
going to call someone you're going to
get caught
right you could probably barely text
well his i mean i don't know what his
plan was but he had to get it surgically
removed oh he couldn't bring it back up
no he was complaining about stomach
pains for several days it's kind of like
the dark knight right when the guy had
this he's like oh michael chubby [ __ ]
yeah dude get over it
so yeah he's taking the gastroente
enterology department where the doctors
discovered a nokia 3310 in his stomach
oh my god doesn't it depend on the level
of prison to or whatever
they give you phones sometimes
did you like earn that yeah like your
phone privileges yeah yeah i just want
to get a cell phone though maybe not
also does the phone work afterwards how
well does it look like
where did he put the charger imagine
he's like oh [ __ ] you charger [ __ ] the
charger that's up his ass
is the cord sticking out
i know how he's gonna get it out he was
really planning on shooting it out yeah
and how do you charge it dude yeah he
could have just had the [ __ ] phone
here the charger here and then clicked
it together
and just plug his [ __ ] there you go
maybe keep it hidden
he didn't really think he was going to
[ __ ] it out he pulls it and he shoots up
that's crazy it's a whole system though
like they could be like oh you know that
guard over there i know that guy's
cousin lives in the hood i'll tell my
cousin stop being your cousin's ass if
you could just charge us from like 10
minutes you know there's like a whole
system that's all right
but no one's got no kia charger unless
we're talking about 1998. it seems
easier to just get a phone that way once
you're in just do favors till one
[ __ ] shows up then just swallow one
and hope it doesn't wreck your gut but
what if the swallower is supposed to be
the favor bringer
it wasn't even muggling
he was the middle man yeah i'm the
amazon of jail and i got caught yeah
dude is that i'm sure that happened he's
the amazon package he probably gets beat
up as soon as he gets the surgery he
gets it out they're like they're gonna
[ __ ] him up for not bringing the phone
yeah they're gonna [ __ ] him up yeah they
should that's so good
put up your butt bro everybody knows
that everyone knows it
maybe he was just like i'll bring it in
but maybe i could just [ __ ] it out this
way have you guys heard about phone time
no what's that you know what phone time
is funtime's a new thing where like so
like there's a lot of um
sports teams and stuff now where they
have practices and you're supposed to be
there all day and now they have like a a
break for phone time because people are
so into their phones it's like a
cigarette break yeah that they need like
their little cigarette break that's
crazy yeah it's a thing
wow so i think this guy needed his phone
time pretty bad
yes addiction yeah that's crazy it went
to his stomach
like it went all the way in oh my god
what's the longest you can go without
checking your phone uh i don't know at
least a day we check
a whole day yeah at least the whole day
yeah
i think so i think more than a day we'll
do it we'll do it tomorrow tomorrow yeah
like if i go on vacation with the family
i know i'm trying to be like there or
something i just put my phone i'll leave
it like in the car or in the rv so i'm
not even tempted it's a treat to have no
phone dude [ __ ] that i was buying nfts
during my dad's birthday song
i'm not kidding i was on my laptop
they're all doing happy birthday around
me all my nieces and nephews are running
all over the [ __ ] place and i'm
buying entities that's that's different
because that's finance related though
like if i'm not doing [ __ ] i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is that i'm not making
money doing this yeah i could see your
motivation if i had stuff like that i'd
be doing that
if you're trading yeah yeah but not like
to check that's profitable it is still
so all addictive and stuff like that
yeah there's so many real bad yeah i
think it's gonna get it's already bad
it's going to get worse
you get everything onto your your your
food
going where to go your dopamine your
career do you believe do you believe
it's linked to like how you don't want
to have certain thoughts like right when
your mind goes idle and you don't want
to think about anything like sad you
just for sure you know like when you
stand in line and there's nothing to do
but think about how bad your life might
be yeah for sure i mean that's what like
tv movies right a little escape or
whatever now your phone's just a
constant infant in the sky you could be
yeah non-stop there's no time for
boredom anymore
but we convince ourselves that there's
important things to check though for
sure i definitely do that for sure it's
absurd and it's like playing roulette
with it too because you never know if it
is going to be interesting or it'll be
garbage now most of it sucks when's the
last time you actually saw something on
like instagram you're like damn that's
actually so it's
changed my life
has anyone ever read something
inspirational on instagram and then was
like i'm going to make a change yeah
yeah i'm going to church like that too
yeah never love life some [ __ ] like that
put the [ __ ] out of here what does that
even mean well yeah because
algorithmically you're just being fed
everything you already think anyways
it's getting choppier and choppier too
like tick tocks are five seconds or five
seconds youtube's [ __ ] 10 seconds
shorts now
wait where's that
10 second shorts yeah it's called
youtube shorts dude can you believe that
now our trailers have trailers like
before the trailer starts there's a
trailer for the trailer right the reveal
yeah the teaser the shit's whack what
does that even mean dude i want to see a
t-shirt when you see the reaction videos
to the [ __ ] reveal
dude reaction videos have blown up oh my
god reacting stuff gets more views than
like the original yeah the thing then
the thing itself it's because people
need to
know that other people think that too or
something you know they're hanging out
with them they do it a lot on twitch and
people just it's like i have no friends
and now i'm watching you react to stuff
so it's like we're kind of hanging out
sounds kind of sad no it's sad dude
we're heading down it's not good because
less and less people are like hanging
out with everybody we have like like not
to get like too serious but yeah we have
like no community in our world no yeah
we were talking about it the other day
was a good community
proud boys great community
those guys
no joke that's why we're talking about
the podcast it's like everyone's finding
their community on their online
idealistic belief of red versus blue
democratic republic rather than crazy
you're your neighbor yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] hit
the fan in kovid and everyone buys guns
to protect them from the neighbor but
i'm repping republican or democrat
online no worries and i have no clue
when [ __ ] hits the fan the republican
party ain't gonna come save me no but
maybe if i had a real community friends
neighbor with diversity actually
i didn't get guns to
protect myself from my neighbors i got
my guns so that i could go get my
neighbor's [ __ ] true
yeah for
everyone for sure toilet paper that's
what everyone was mostly for toilet
paper yeah i'm like
you know i didn't stock up so i'm gonna
need to like
i wasn't prepared i saw i saw you go to
costco yesterday
okay
okay [ __ ] don't think about chicken
bakes
chicken bacon
bacon with all the hungry bands
yeah i love how out of all the things
that could have been a shortage it was a
paper shortage yeah
food how much i asked you i know and it
was purely because people were buying
them in crazy amounts that was the only
reason why it's also the only thing that
saved me
because i had toilet paper during covid
because i went to costco first and nikki
was like eye rolling and you were
bartering with everybody you don't need
this much toilet paper you idiot and all
[ __ ] and then during kovid guess who was
her [ __ ] king yep guess who saved her
after her face every day yep didn't give
her any toilet paper oh would you like
to use some toilet paper
oh my hero good thing we have some yeah
good thing you had a stupid guy i
remember i was very stupid remember i
was the dumb guy